Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 13th,
2014.
How's it going?
How I yeah,
what's going on?
Is Everything go,
we're here.
Was everything go with you?
Well,
yeah.
You look good machine.
You for what else is going on?
Oh yeah.
Oh that's good.
Mic got nothing,
you know,
same.
Oh Shit.
My fucking boss.
You know,
he's breaking my balls where I'm not going to bore you with it.
Do or do you think about the patch and they full fucking real.
It's like,
you know,
which team are they?
Um,
I'm actually doing this out of my living room.
That's why I have the echo out here.
Um,
you know,
like the old capitol records thing that they used to do,
right.
[inaudible]
um,
we've got construction workers downstairs,
Sophie here,
some fucking banging around or whatever.
That's just them finishing up,
finishing up the Goddamn job.
I always wonder what they think when I'm up here fucking singing and screaming
and saying,
can't,
you know,
they probably think I'm yelling at my wife a bitch and about the job that don't,
maybe if they didn't have real jobs,
stayed,
have time to listen to the podcast like you,
like you are right now.
How dare you in the middle of a fucking workweek in the United States of
America.
You just sitting here listening to this shit.
You know,
aren't we slipping enough?
Yeah.
Oh,
what are the fuck you are around the world.
Do you know?
This weekend I went out and I did a,
I did a show at the spotlight 29 casino with the let there be talks.
Uh,
Dean del Ray of the letter B talked podcast and uh,
Joe Bart,
Nick Rosebowl legend and host of the puck off.
Yeah.
Um,
podcasts and the PS popping.
I gotta turn this fucking volume down here.
Um,
anyways,
the,
um,
we went out there,
we hit,
we had a great time,
but we were on our way out there and,
um,
we're on the highway and I'm thinking,
all right,
there's fucking,
yeah,
three of us here.
We can use the Carpool lane.
And recently I've been getting these tickets for writing.
I Dunno what going through tolls and not paying.
And I'm like,
where the hell was that?
And there's pictures of my car and shit and I'm on the highway.
I had no idea what it was.
And uh,
I was riding out with those guys and they finally explained what it was.
They said,
um,
that a private group bought up a section of the,
of the highway out here in Los Angeles.
And um,
okay.
They own it.
And when you use it,
you got to pay them money,
you got to give them toll money and all that type of shit.
And uh,
that was really scary to me because if they were going to do that,
why wouldn't the state just do it?
Why would they just say,
well fuck it.
We'll just do it and we'll collect that money.
God knows we could use it,
right,
but instead they sold it off to somebody.
So what that says to me is just state is so fucking bankrupt.
They don't even have time to just,
you know,
just collect money on roads that they already own.
They have to sell off like a giant section of a highway.
Who's that group that owns the giant section of the highway and how the fuck do
I get involved in that?
That,
that business?
I'll parachute right outta here.
I'll never,
I'll do like fucking a podcast.
Seven days,
a goddamn week.
I'll never go on the road again.
Won't tell any jokes.
And you guys can just listen to me.
Slowly slipped into madness.
Yeah.
Do you realize how fucking cool.
This is one of the greatest investments of all time.
I own a stripper.
Like I own five miles of a fucking highway outside one of the most populated
cities ever whip.
There's no public transportation for the most part.
Everybody's in a car
and every time they go up through that fucking thing,
Dang.
Okay.
45 cents 45 cents 45 cents,
45 cents and I'm sitting here on my fucking couch.
Yeah,
just sitting here,
the bag of pretzels and a fucking Miller high life,
right?
Just sitting here.
45 cents.
45 cents is the greatest fucking thing ever.
Oh,
and I know you do do it.
What about the overhead?
What about it?
It's already fucking made.
When do you have to pave it?
Once every four or five years,
if that.
I remember back in the day,
the Mass Pike,
the whole time I was there,
they paved that thing one time.
I don't know what it is.
Whatever man who gives a fuck.
How much could that,
well shit,
that could cost a lot of money.
Wait a minute and all,
if you do any sort of driveway,
they always come in.
Oh,
going to be about 20 grand.
Is it more like three?
Um,
that that could get expensive.
I guess that could get expensive,
but dude,
I'm telling you that is the move.
If you can somehow get in with the people that are going to start buying up the
fucking roads over here
and Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I would be such an obnoxious ass if I was making money like that.
I'd start wearing wife beaters and I'd have a fucking gold piece hanging around
my neck that just said 45 cents.
45 cents,
45 cents owed.
It's slowly just go fucking nuts.
Thinking about it being like that guy.
Pick up the papers,
pick out the pavers.
Hey Bill,
what do you want for lunch?
Let me get a roast beef sandwich.
45 cents.
25 cents.
Yeah,
don't worry.
he gives you a little weird.
He's a little weird,
but don't want me to do it.
He's fucking painful.
The whole lunch.
You know,
we uh,
just kind of repeats himself a little bit.
Um,
so whoever did that,
ah,
good on you and whoever has been an office out here in California,
uh,
fuck you.
You spineless cunt.
All of you.
How the fuck do you go bankrupt as a God damn state.
Everybody going to work everyday.
You want to talk about 45 cents,
45 cents.
These mother fuckers are getting money from everybody.
You're getting free money,
free money,
taxes,
free money.
Hey,
I'm going to go buy a fucking Chapeau.
Put It on my big stupid roundhead.
All right,
that'll be $8 plus fucking,
you know,
whatever.
80 cents tax.
There you go.
You didn't have to do a fucking thing.
State government did you?
Oh,
you had to do is sit around and wait for me to go out and go buy a fucking hat.
Free money.
Here you go.
Coming in.
Big Pile of fucking loot and then you blow all of it.
Okay.
How do you go bankrupt as a state?
Jesus fucking Christ.
Unbelievable.
Why don't you want to hear your fucking excuses?
Well,
you know,
big Shit,
loose judge book,
my own hotel we,
oh by oh way.
I mean you got fucking the highway goes,
you know from San Diego all the way up out.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You know what's in there around all those highways.
A zillion fucking people are giving you money every time they go out to go by
themselves,
you know,
so of condoms and a pair of socks.
You're fucking making money.
You've got plenty of goddamn money.
But this is what happens.
All right?
The fuck in public servants,
the people who hold office,
they don't make any money.
They make no fucking money.
I don't know what a senator makes.
I know the president makes 400 grand a fucking year.
Okay?
So if you're governor of Los Angeles,
what are you taking down a year?
What a hundred grand,
a hundred grand to have everybody in the fucking city say that you're a piece of
shit.
You're fucking everything up,
right?
You've got to have security.
So nobody comes up and fucking shanks Ya.
Every time you go out to go get a club sandwich.
And not to mention it costs millions and millions and millions of dollars to
campaign to get that fucker job.
And in the end,
all you get is a hundred grand.
Yeah.
Those guys,
they are set up to be bribed.
I,
this is 100% believe this shit.
So basically you're going for a job that's gonna get you a hundred grand and you
need millions and millions of dollars to fucking get the thing.
So now you got to get in bed with all these fat cats that can fucking buy up the
goddamn highways and that's what they do.
Right Day.
What I'll finance you for listening to me.
Fucking shut up.
I'm going to fucking,
what do you need?
Money.
How much money you need for this?
Huh?
Eight,
seven,
9 million.
What the fuck do you need?
All right.
Hey,
2040 68 fucking keep it.
All right,
but all right,
I or II and in return you got to give me,
you've got to give me 10 miles of the fucking 10 or the five.
We get the five full of fucking hippies driving up to San Francisco.
Let me get 10 10 miles of that and I'm not finished.
Let me get 10 miles of that and uh,
let's make,
let's make it a no fly zone over Rod Disneyland.
Whatever the fuck they want.
Right?
Okay.
Then that's what happens or whatever.
You know what I'm going to do with this job I'm going to repay.
Let me be the guy who fucking repaved it.
I'm going to donate $2 million to your fucking campaign so you can get this job
that makes a hundred grand a fucking year and maybe eventually get to the White
House.
So you get that Marilyn Monroe side pussy,
and then you get to go on the fucking golden parachute million dollar a speech
fucking Gig after you retire.
And in the meantime,
um,
I want the contract to do this job for the state and I'm going to charge you
fucking $9 million for a hammer as the old fucking urban legend goes.
And that's how you go fucking bankrupt.
There you go.
Look at that dummy like me.
That's my theory.
I'm anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
As I mentioned.
Um,
that was a good 10 minutes of horseshit Kaur,
spelled w is it a horse shit like you fucking who?
Uh,
or is it horse shit
and you just seem so fast.
It's whore.
You know what?
I'm going to Google that right now.
Let me see.
Let we look up horse shit.
You know if you curse as much as I do.
She really fine dictionary Horse Shit.
It is a word shit whore.
Shit Bitch.
Horfish or face or this she used still horse shit.
Not embarrassed at all.
She's used to horse shit or is it horse shit.
I think we can all agree.
It's definitely bullshit,
right?
Girls on IRC,
this is urban dictionary.
which I don't know what that is,
who are desperate for attention and will latch onto any scum they find also gets
naked on cam for attention and sends out pics of themselves committing.
Oh Dee Dee acts to their anus.
Jesus' question.
What's funny about to fucking urban dictionary,
just like the Webster in the dictionary.
You've got to look up like another five fucking words.
Odd.
I remember Aux DB.
That was old.
Dirty bastard.
Old Dirty Dick.
What I'm sends out picks themselves committing to o d d x.
I feel like the white cop on Sanford and son right now.
What's going off?
I'm also,
Oh,
d d
what the fuck would that be?
Okay.
Other dudes,
dicks
out pictures of themselves committing other dudes.
Dicks x to that doesn't make sense.
Not Jesus Christ.
Now I gotta look this up.
See what happens.
This is how you lose a whole fucking day.
This is why nothing is getting done in this country.
Cause you're fucking go to the urban dictionary is a white guy like me,
oppositional defiant disorder.
Now what?
The Jesus,
you know what?
I don't even give a fuck anymore.
Oh my God.
He has odd force him forced drug him.
It can't have anything to do with ridiculous success of punishment is
jurisdictions operational defiant disorder.
Surprisingly,
it's real.
A fake ass.
This disorder pulled out of their asses of a small collective of psychiatrists
working for pharmaceutical companies in order to maximize revenue.
Of course,
there's no a in,
you know what's funny?
I don't even know what I'm talking about anymore.
All right,
I'll chalk that up to be white as fuck.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Um,
do you guys bup,
Bup,
Bup Buda,
Buda,
Buda bad,
boop,
boop.
Let that bit,
but bow.
Did you guys watch any of the football this week?
Of course you did.
You had nothing better to do.
Just like make you like how I'm doing that.
I'm dragging you into my own fucking world.
Um,
I actually didn't watch too much of it.
I was running around like a maniac.
Um,
I did watch my patriots.
don't let the final score full year was a lot closer than you thought it was.
I mean,
we were only up by eight with four minutes to go against the buffalo bills.
This is why I can't,
I can't buy into the Patriots team yet.
People like,
Oh,
you know,
it'd be tobacco.
You know,
we are close game against the Raiders.
Right?
Dave stuck.
I just stunk it.
I don't know.
They've stumps and stay where they were in la.
Who's kitten home?
No,
that's not true.
They had the,
uh,
the snow cone game where they lost us because of an obscure rule.
I love all raider fans think that that game was bullshit.
It wasn't bullshit.
The rule was bullshit,
but the call was not bullshit.
It was right on the money.
What was bullshit was the roughing the passer call against Sugar Bay Hamilton
that got the radio and just super bowl 11 all right,
so quit your crying.
Go put on your makeup and your stupid fucking costume and go sit in the end zone
and think that you're intimidating somebody.
Oh,
you might intimidate me.
I'm in the stage.
No one gives a shit about me,
but you're not going to intimidate a professional football player with the God
damn outfit.
When I look at when I,
when I bite into a York peppermint patty,
when I look into the fucking end zone of the Goddamn or eight is right and I see
the sadness that,
that,
that fan base has become,
I'll never get over cause I fucking love the Raiders.
I,
that is one of the most,
that is arguably the best logo in all on national football.
The everybody who the fuck hasn't tried to rip off putting some of black and do
their uniform to try to be more intimidating or at least the amount of people
who have,
right.
Okay.
Atlanta Falcons,
the old Houston Oilers.
Then they do that.
Or Jerry Glanville just went out and got a black jacket at fucking idiot.
He shouldn't have been a head coach.
He should have been on like Falcon Crest.
Um,
or the dukes of hazards or something like that.
Who else?
Everybody for a while,
I can't remember.
Everybody would are we switched to uniforms to black cause they want to be more
fucking intimidating when they rate these were smart enough from day one,
right?
The silver and black and they had a fucking pirate on the side of the helmet.
They've never had to change it.
Look at,
look at every fucking team out there had to change.
It had to eventually was like,
all right,
you know,
what the fuck were we thinking in 1960 or 19 whatever.
Everybody has fucked with their God goddamn low logos except for the radios.
They never had to.
They got it right.
Right out of the gate.
Like that fat fuck they pull out of the stands to try to hit a half court
fucking shot.
Right.
So he can go out and go win a fucking dodge opal or whatever the fuck they're
given away.
Oh my God,
I can't even afford.
Right.
Some meaty fat tit fucking moron goes out there.
Nothing button that,
that's what they did back in 1968 sure.
This other teams that couldn't admitted that they fucked up like the dolphins.
When you really think about the dolphins,
that is probably the worst fucking name considering the sharks was still on.
That was still available.
They could have been the sharks.
They could add some bad ass fucking logo.
I mean,
if you're going to go with some sort of porpoise type looking fish,
right?
What do they do?
They pick the dolphins.
Why don't you just call yourselves the pussies?
Right?
That logo should have had a fucking beach ball right on the end of it's God damn
nose join.
Anyways,
they,
but they stick with this thing for so goddamn long.
They went to super bowls.
They go undefeated back when you played like fucking 12 games and nobody gave a
shit.
There was no pressure whatsoever.
Right.
They went to another two super bowls.
I think,
yeah.
And then eighties one with dawn struck and one with uh,
Dan Marino and after awhile you just kind of forgiveness kind of forgot that
they were the dolphins and they had that silly ass logo and it never dawned on
me again how stupid that fucking name and logo was until they changed it.
They changed it.
What?
Last year?
I think they changed it last year.
I think I already made fun of the logo,
but whenever I look at that logo,
that logo to me looks like it's the logo of a corporation that just had a
massive fucking oil spill in the Gulf.
And now they're trying to pretend like they give a shit about the environment.
So they switch up their logo.
You know,
it's kind of like BP did.
They put like fucking looks like corn and grass is the color of their logo.
Like,
oh Whoa,
they care about us.
They care about the trees.
Um,
they don't.
all right.
How far into this fucking podcast are we at this point?
18 minutes.
Another fucking nine minutes of bullshit.
There we go.
Will.
It's time for a little bit of advertising.
All right,
here we go.
Everybody,
me,
undies,
Andy's cup and my fucking balls.
Bodo boop,
boop.
My Andy's Biondi my dick and balls.
That's all not riding up my fucking crack.
All right.
It's unbelievable how putting on a great pair of underwear changes your entire
outlook for the day.
That is not a joke.
Feeling that velvety smooth material
up against your privates.
You know that feeling of putting on that ratty old saggy underwear.
Oh my God,
dude,
we got it.
I want you to know the feeling of wearing great fitting,
great looking underwear like Jim fucking Paul.
You need to know more about me.
undies.com me undies has the most comfortable underwear you have ever tried on.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you.
Of course it fit perfectly.
There's not that much material.
It's like you make it pants.
What are you going to measure the end scene with somebody fucking taint.
Um,
I actually,
I've heard these a great,
by the way.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you and they literally pull moisture away from your gross
from your skin.
So you're cool all day long.
That doesn't make any sense.
Okay?
You have your sweat to cool yourself off.
Now your point pulling the moisture away.
Why don't you just come out and say it me undies.
You're not going to have sweaty balls as long as you wear our stuff.
Me,
Andy's Biondi,
no more sweaty balls.
Badoo but here's the thing,
they also make you look great.
What does that mean?
Okay?
Did they frame you have package like a strike that hits the fucking corner.
Um,
go to me undies.com and check out pictures of all different styles of underwear
and for girls.
Checkout those hot looking boy shorts,
men and women,
high quality materials for your high quality materials.
Oh,
I get it.
Yeah,
if you know what I mean.
Sorry,
I totally blew that.
High quality materials for your high quality materials,
if you know what I mean.
The price.
Glad you asked a fraction of what typically high end designers charge.
Who the hell buys designer underwear?
It's like having a designer fucking piping in your walls.
Oh my God.
Is that your initials on the pipes?
I can't see here.
I'll help you up.
Go to me undies.com/bur bur get 20% off your first order,
20% off your order when you go to [inaudible] com slash burr and right now
you'll even get shipping.
You'll get free shipping in the United States and Canada.
So basically if you live in north,
the America,
north of Mexico and central amount,
she's a hammering down there north of all Central America.
For some reason,
you know Central America,
they're not focusing on you think that that's where the most sweaty balls are
going to be at,
right?
Isn't this a sketch on fucking SNL?
My schweddy balls.
Um,
basically the United States and Canada,
the highest concentration of white people with sweaty balls are in the North
American area.
And for years we have walked around with a devastating condition of hot balls.
Well,
thank God since me undies came on,
the list came on the scene.
All right,
you get it.
People.
All right.
Draft Kings.
Everyone lists.
Listeners are winning huge cash prize every,
let me start over again.
Draft Kings.
Oh Jesus.
Yeah.
What in God's name could they be doing down there?
I think that putting in the fucking floors.
All right.
Draft Kings,
everyone.
Yeah.
Listening listeners are winning huge cash prizes every week@draftkings.com
America's favorite one week fantasy football site one week fantasy means no
season.
Long commitments play whenever you want.
Got An injured player,
not a problem.
At draft kings where it's like a new season every week so you're never stuck
with the same players.
Pick your team in minutes and you could be on your way to winning instant cash.
Last year,
one player turned 11 bucks into four grant and another one a hundred grand for
his first time ever playing and another player won a million bucks in one day.
Just playing fantasy football.
Okay,
hurry and get a free and get free entry into the $100,000 fantasy football
contest this weekend.
We're first place takes home $10,000 call to action is what I'm supposed to get
really intense head off and a draft.
kings.com now and enter the Promo code defense to play for free.
draftkings.com bigger events,
bigger winnings.
Big a million is yet the defense for reentry.
now@draftkingsdotcomdraftkings.com.
That once again,
it's draft kings.com because of that man right there.
All right,
then we'll change censored.
Um,
all right.
There you go.
I think that's fucking hilarious.
There's a couple things that are really,
when you watch like an NFL football game,
did you have you like watch the advertising?
Like how much of a fucking like psycho loser they think you are?
Hm.
First of all,
they've run in that fucking,
that Ad.
Every 10 minutes.
Don't hit women no more,
no more.
She slipped on the coffee cake no more.
I asked,
I was stretching and accidentally pushed her down the stairs.
No more,
no more.
Uh,
we were playing football and she tried to block a kick.
She tried to block the punt.
Don't,
she was roughing me.
She not supposed to run into the kicking follow up.
My fault.
My fucking sneakerhead affects,
you know.
Um,
so they got that going.
I said basically why they think we're wife beaters.
Alright.
Every five seconds she got some Sorta,
you know your Dick doesn't get hard and you're going bald.
You're balding limp Dick wifebeater.
Right.
And then they run the fucking draft kings.
You're a degenerate gambler.
You're a degenerate gambling,
bald,
limp Dick fucking wife beater.
Nothing positive.
They're fucking,
no more commercial.
Fucking annoys me because I feel like they yelling at me and I don't hit women.
So why don't you fucking tone it down a little bit?
Yeah.
Okay.
Actually tweeted this out.
You know when you watch a w NBA game,
but they start yelling at all the broads watching that shit.
Okay.
You know,
no more marrying a guy just because he's got money.
Okay,
but you don't love them no more.
I'm used to a certain lifestyle.
Do they do that shit?
Of course.
Say Down if he could sit of fine or something fucking wrong thing that don't no
more campaign and everybody's dressed all in black,
you know,
like they get on the cover of the fucking Beatles album.
You know,
my favorite part of all of it.
Can somebody please explain to me how they didn't do a like didn't do any sort
of background check on ice tea and he got in that fucking commercial
according to his albums.
Wasn't he a pimp at some point?
I don't know.
I don't know much about the pimp game,
but as far as I know,
you know if you started off as a pimp,
you probably made your first million smacking bitches every couple of seconds.
Ah Bitch.
Where's my money?
Okay.
Oh,
I love ice tea.
Every time you fucking see that guy,
he's always talking about the street.
Okay.
You know,
Yo,
I could make,
I could make five grand at 20 minutes every fucking time.
I don't give a fuck what you bring up.
Ice Tea is going to bring up the street and how much money he could make.
How quickly.
Hey,
ice tea.
Isn't it a beautiful day out here?
I'll tell you,
it was beautiful when I was out on the street.
I could make five Wayne and 20 minutes.
Yeah.
It was just kind of talking about the weather.
Every fucking one of those VH one things from 10 years ago.
All those behind the musics,
anything,
blah,
blah.
Why don't give a fuck what they were talking about.
Ice Tea eventually came on and told you that he could make five grand at 20
minutes.
When I was out on the street,
the pimp game,
see the pimp game.
Oh,
shut up about the fucking pimp and gave
hey,
know that that whole thing is romanticized.
See when you get some runaway to go out and sell her pussy for money and there's
an art to it,
is it you fucking creep?
You know,
it's funny,
I didn't even know was was he your pimp?
All those albums fucking ran together.
They all came out.
They was so fucking overwhelming.
When I first heard of,
you know,
I'm sitting here,
little white boy living in the CULDESAC and all of a sudden easy and all these
guys came out.
I could,
I couldn't keep up with WHO's getting shot,
who was getting smacked.
So I might be wrong on that one,
but am I the only one who was like,
wait a minute.
That's that guy who can make five grand at 20 minutes smacking bitches out there
and selling crack,
right?
No more.
Oh Jesus.
I didn't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Anyway,
so let's get down to the football this week.
So I watched the Patriots,
obviously it was a big victory on the afcs,
the weak limp Dick fucking AFC east Jesus Christ.
Man.
What has happened to the fucking jets,
but the Betty and the jets,
they're fucking fallen off the face of the earth.
Now what a lot of people would think that the Patriots are going to have an easy
victory cub this Thursday or Thursday night football.
And I'm here to tell you that probably won't happen.
I'm actually not buying it cause uh oh,
jet's always play as tough.
All right,
I'm going to sell you a bad game.
The patriots versus the jets Thursday night football.
All right.
You know,
I'll tell you the church and they got their backs up against the wall.
I wouldn't count out this rex ray tune.
There's still part Jewish says to him.
I know they've launched now games you a fucking rope.
Um,
they're actually in a,
uh,
it was actually a rough,
a rough week,
uh,
for um,
New York football giants got the shit kicked out of the eagles.
Really?
That fucking good.
I mean,
I don't know.
I just kept thinking how the Gyra at the giants are going to make some sort of
halftime adjustments at some point.
Right.
It was brutal though.
Huh?
Cruz got fucking that brutal injury.
Oh,
look at this shit.
Here I'm on the New York Post.
Hard to believe radio hosts excuse for mocking crews.
Injury of Philadelphia Radio House added insult to injury Sunday night mocking
giant star receivers,
Victor Cruz after he injured his right knee in the second half loss.
How is it hard to believe that anybody in Philly does anything other than I
guess if they act like human beings and it's actually hard to believe a cruiser
would just drop the fourth down,
pass in the end zone,
tore his patellar tendon out on the play and immediately grabbed his knee.
Mike,
Miss Aneli,
a Mike fucking Miss Aneli,
a radio host for 97.5 the fanatic made fun of cruises,
salsa dancing as he rides in pain.
I gotta admit that's kind of funny.
A giant fans,
Rick Victor Cruz is over dance to that.
Oh God.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
I thought he was going to be,
I have pop pop out.
I tell you to do something like that,
that that would have made me laugh.
As Cruz was carted and tears,
the fans in attendance at Lincoln financial field gave him his sincere round of
applause.
Oh,
look at that.
See,
look at me.
I'm saying all eagle fans of bad.
It gets on and missing like soon.
Backtrack,
DTA,
deleting the tweet and replacing it with multiple apologies.
Uh,
somebody was home drunk watching the game.
A giant fish is done.
Dance to that tweet.
Just sitting there laughing.
That's a good one.
Then get me some more lists and all of a sudden all the hate starts coming in.
You start sweating all over the place except down his balls because he's wearing
me undies.
Me undies,
no more sweaty balls.
Um,
this is what he wrote.
He said,
I apologize for the cruise tweet.
I didn't see that he got hurt on the play,
was outside the stadium and saw he dropped it walking to my car.
You lying.
Sack of shit.
He goes,
I just saw on big screen outside stadium that he dropped the past.
Didn't see that he got hurt on my,
on the play.
My bad.
I would never have tweeted that.
Had I known he got injured.
Please know that.
No what?
You're full of Shit,
dude.
Victor Cruz is over right there.
That means you know he got hurt.
Ah,
Jesus.
You know what?
This guy doesn't need me undies.
BRD,
no more sweaty balls because he doesn't have any balls.
Just say,
listen,
I was at the game.
I got fucking a Hammock and I made a joke that a lot of people made.
I was actually in a cigar bar last night watching the game and somebody made
that joke.
Um,
and people laugh,
but it was more like,
ah,
you know,
but you know what the fuck you gonna sit there and what [inaudible] Papo every
time you score a touchdown,
the jokes just laying there waiting for somebody to say it.
Um,
he could find that with some alcohol and you combine that,
he's in Philly,
so he's gotta be at least three quarters of a fucking animal.
Animal voice is cracking.
Um,
actually had a great time.
I went to this awesome cigar bar last night and I watched the,
uh,
giants eagles game.
You know,
the game was just fucking,
it was just was so one sided.
It was just a wall.
Why,
why it or why an ass kicking.
Um,
and we were actually was sitting there and,
um,
Jesus Christ,
the hammering right underneath me.
This is what has been people for the last fucking six months.
I know what you're thinking.
Six months.
Jesus built,
what,
are they rebuilding the whole downstairs?
Yes.
Yes they are.
And now they're going to put it in the hardwood floors and then they found out
the floor wasn't level and the guy fucking goes,
hey bill a MOOC this downstairs area ever outside.
Yeah,
it was,
let me guess,
let me guess.
It used to be some sort of half ass porch,
so they had it raked,
you know,
and have a nice fucking whatever,
15 degree angle.
So the rain water would roll off it.
Now it's inside
whatever.
What'd you downstairs in my house.
Do you just feel like you're on a boat that's making a left turn or a right turn
depending on which way you walk.
And I don't give a fuck.
Not,
it's not that bad.
I never even noticed to be honest with you.
But um,
you know,
he went down there with a level and that little ball just kind of rolled a
little bit to the side.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck,
you know,
I give a fuck,
but I just,
I don't have any more money.
I don't have any more money to throw at that.
Okay.
I'm cutting you off.
All right son,
it's over.
You've got to get out in the world and get a fucking job.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
went out there with a couple of buddies,
smoked a couple of cigars and uh,
was watching the game.
It just was just a wire to wire fucking beat down.
And um,
I don't know.
I was disappointed in the game.
I was impressed.
Obviously with Philly.
I know the giant started off rough.
They've been playing better.
Um,
but still I didn't think it was going to go like that.
And I've actually,
I've always loved the NFC east.
It's always just been a,
it's always been great football,
great rivalries and that type of thing.
It's sucked that the,
the,
the Redskins have not been a factor for so long cause those cowboy Redskins
games were always great when I was growing up.
Um,
but I guess there's always one team that's going to suck and you division
somebody has got to come in last.
It's just been them for a while.
Um,
for whatever reason.
all right.
Is that all I had to say in football?
I honestly didn't watch a lot.
Um,
I would have to think that they're fucking calling for Rex Ryan's head at this
point.
Are they still sticking with the,
I still sticking with the guy.
I'm actually going to be upset if he gets fired because I love watching him
loose,
you know,
and if they fire him,
I don't get to do that anymore.
All right,
here we go.
And Eh,
what do we got here?
Spit it up.
Hill.
New York Post's sports.
All right.
Kevin Doran hurt his foot,
the Yankees.
A rod mysteries and much deeper than you think.
Ah,
a Rod.
My favorite Yankee of all time.
The $200 million Albatross.
Um,
let's see.
Gronk swagger returning to the Patriots.
Uh,
I see he gets,
he made a quote,
they should get laid.
What the fuck?
Um,
jets picked six ending gambling miracle for Broncos backers.
Yeah.
I don't see them getting saying get rid of Rex Ryan yet.
Well,
that's very surprising for the New York Post.
They usually got,
the sky is falling up the two fucking days.
Um,
all right.
And I gotta look up this story here.
Sorry guys.
I'm just,
you just listen to me.
Read the newspaper this week.
Gronk swagger to the Patriots.
They should get laid.
Rob Gronkowski is oh,
is always looking out for his teammates falling New England's decisive 30,
22 when I love how it was decisive,
we were up by eight
with four minutes to go.
Somebody didn't watch the game.
He just looked at the final score.
Um,
37,
22 wine over the bills on Sunday.
The Patriots' tight in,
wanted to give credit to the often overlooked or offensive line.
He gives this,
they're the ones who should,
oh,
they're the ones who should get laid tonight.
Growing.
Koski said that it's,
that's very nice of them seeing that wasn't bad.
It wasn't bad at all.
Um,
all right,
enough with the frigging football.
How about the baseball?
Okay,
how about the baseball?
Bup,
bup,
bup.
Oh,
you guys been watching that shit?
I'm in watching the,
uh,
the royals.
I haven't watched the giants cat and holes.
I saw the cardinals had a walk off last night,
which is awesome.
Um,
but
hang on a second.
Where the fuck did that story go?
God Damn it.
Yeah.
The New York Post actually had a fucking great story about some nurse cause I
don't want to have this all be sports and they listen to you guys fucking
whining at me.
Oh move.
Would you do you for the people who don't look forwards.
All right,
nurse,
here's one for you.
If for people who aren't into sports,
nurse accused of killing 38 patients,
she found annoying
cops arrested a nurse in northeast Italy.
A are you doing and connection with deaths of as many as 38 patients who she say
she whom she may have killed because she found them or their relatives.
Annoying.
Wow.
Daniella Porgy Isley,
a 42 year old resident from the town of Lugo was taken into custody over the
weekend and booked for allegedly slang as the alleged slang of a 78 year old
patient rose that killed their own.
He who died from an injection of potassium Calderon.
He had been admitted to the hospital with a routine illness before she died.
Unexpectedly test show.
She died with a high amount of potassium,
which can provide provoked cardiac arrest in her bloodstream.
According to Central European news,
her death triggered an investigation which found that 38 others had died
mysteriously.
Why pogie Ali was on duty.
The news agency reported one of Pogie alleys.
Fellow nurses described her as a cold person,
but always eager to work.
Wow.
Another one of [inaudible] colleagues said that the accused nurse was once
reported for giving powerful laxative to patients at the end of her shift to
make work tougher for the nurse.
The nurses working after her
filed under crime,
Comma,
Italy.
Jesus Christ.
There's a person who never got hugged as a child.
Huh?
What a fucking so,
I mean,
I shouldn't say that,
man.
You know,
cause she hasn't been convicted of anything.
Why did,
why do they do that?
Why do they protect the alleged victim but not the alleged accused?
I saw something last night that was saying that this,
this person out here attacked a 68 year old woman with like a broomstick or
something outside of a fucking ATM.
And so then they show this guy's face,
right?
And the judge just random fucking name.
They're like,
yeah,
they show the guy's face on TV,
his mugshot.
And they go,
uh,
and that is when Scott Walker allegedly took a broomstick and smash a 68 year
old woman over their head with it at an ATM.
It's like allegedly,
you don't even know if you've got the right fucking guy.
This guy's face is all over the fucking news.
Why did the,
why did we have to see somebody's face before they convicted?
I don't understand that.
Like,
you know,
how do you fucking make a comeback from that?
Hey,
aren't you the guy who alleged who got accused?
Accused fucking,
yeah,
I wonder,
does the work he accused the psalter of a 68 year old woman?
Like how do you get it fucking job after that?
Um,
anyway,
so the amount of times that they get the wrong person,
don't you think that they should maybe hold off on showing the photo?
Anybody?
Bueller?
Anybody at all?
Does anybody give a shit on any level whatsoever?
Where the hell's my recorder?
Don't even tell me.
Don't even tell me I knocked it off.
Ah,
fuck.
Okay,
good.
I thought for half a second.
I shut it off.
I'm actually late today cause old Billy boys got a day job.
Oh,
Billy boys get a day job right in a fucking show then.
I can't wait for you guys to see,
but I'm not allowed to talk about it until they announce it.
Once they announce it.
I'll give you a little bit of hype on it.
I think you're going to enjoy it.
So all I can fucking say,
Hey,
I want to thank everybody who came out to the spotlight 29 casino to see a Dean
del Rey,
Joe Barton.
It get myself.
We had a,
we had a wonderful time out there.
Um,
I've got to do more standup though,
man.
I really miss doing it.
I've been writing this fucking show and uh,
kind of burning it at both ends.
So,
uh,
I get to figure that out.
But I'm,
I'm basically straight out right in this thing until thanksgiving.
And then my schedule eases up a little bit more.
I do have coming up,
I got some great gigs coming up.
I'm doing the 20th anniversary of comics come home.
The great thing that,
a great benefit foundation,
whatever the hell you call it,
the Denis leary and Cam Neely,
um,
started 20 years ago for the Cam Nealy House,
which basically when,
um,
unfortunately I think cam lost both of his parents.
I know at least one of his parents,
he lost to cancer and uh,
you know,
they weren't like the hospital and that of thing.
So they've made up the Cam Nealy House.
And so it's just a place like during treatment where people can,
rather than sitting in a hospital can actually feel at home.
It's a great thing.
And it's 20 years.
I can't believe that because I did either comics come home,
two or three.
Yeah,
way back in 1996.
So,
I don't know if they were 94,
95,
96 that was number three.
If this is the 20th one,
does this the 20th 20 years or the 20th one.
You know what I mean?
Like he played 19 years,
20 seasons.
Like I can't figure it out,
but whatever.
This is either the 20th of the 20th year that they've been doing it and um,
I'm going to be up there and it's going to be an absolute murderer's row of a
standup comedians on that thing.
And uh,
one of them I can't wait to see is going to be Steven Wright who is
arguably one of the best comedians I've ever seen.
I mean,
he is,
there's no argument there.
He just is.
I can't wait to see him and uh,
it's going to be awesome.
So I got that going on and then the next day,
um,
I'm going to be a giggles comedy club and Saga Saga on like November 9th doing a
benefit up there.
And then the following week I'm out in Florida.
And what does that,
I didn't know what the fucking date is.
One on a 100.
I look here Homina Homina Homina.
Um,
in November,
I'm basically,
I'm going off for Thursday night football when the,
uh,
the dolphins play the bills and,
I'm going to the Thursday night game and then the next night I am in a,
can you tell,
I'm trying to open windows.
That's why I'm fucking talking slower.
I mean,
uh,
the,
I'm at the West Palm Beach Improv in West Palm Beach,
Florida,
and uh,
doing a couple shows there,
uh,
me,
Paul Versey and uh,
and the next day I'm going to the Miami Hurricane Florida Seminole game.
Unfortunately,
it's where the Miami hurricanes place,
so I don't want to listen too much of that.
Oh,
whoa,
whoa.
Fortunately I won't have to do that.
The amount of people who do that and actually think that that's,
you know,
like native Americans actually used to do that.
Like that's actually one of their songs rather than,
it was just some horse shit that Hollywood made up that and going woo,
they'll that bullshit.
You know,
it's so fucking crazy is how that stuck around for this Goddamn long that people
came up with that shit.
Do you understand that?
They came up with that shit when people didn't even know how to act yet,
at least on film or whatever like that.
That was like 30 years before a why I oughta let me tell you something,
Shea,
all of that stupid fucking horrible acting before Marlon Brando came around and
changes the game.
Um,
what's up Cleo?
What are you doing?
Come here buddy.
[inaudible]
how you doing?
Good to see you.
Good design.
Huh?
You taking a nap?
Yeah.
That was rough,
wasn't it?
Going to the side of the house.
Relieving yourself and then eating a whole fucking can of dog food.
You must be exhausted.
I can really see why you have to go there and take another nap.
Huh?
What do you do all day?
Nothing.
Why you always sleeping?
I want an answer.
Not the microphone.
Right in their muzzle.
I get nothing.
I get Outta here.
All right.
Okay.
Go on.
Fucking love that dog.
Fucking love that dog,
man.
Um,
I will never not have a dog,
you know.
In fact,
you know,
this one here,
if we got another dog would probably try to kill it unless it was a baby boy
from what I heard.
So I don't need that drama in my house.
My dogs just psycho because somebody beat the shit out of it before I got it.
Um,
so I'm going to keep this dog,
you know,
and uh,
hopefully God willing.
How old is she?
Five,
six years.
I want to think about this however long she lasts.
And uh,
but then,
then the next round I'm getting to,
I mean,
need a blue nose and a red nose,
a pity couple of puppies and uh,
that's it.
I'm always going to have fucking dog.
So you just make your life better.
They really do.
So anyways,
hey,
listen to this.
Oh,
Billy fucking booze bag is a,
is seven days.
Eight days.
I haven't drank in eight days.
It's fucking great.
Now I'm ready to go on a fucking run.
It's all it takes is those you guys trying to knock off the booze unless you're
have like a serious fucking alcoholic,
which fortunately I don't suffer from that.
Um,
it takes like five days for me is the tipping point.
If I'm like three,
four days in,
I'm like,
Eh,
this doesn't seem like a streak.
You know,
like,
ah,
you know what I mean?
I'm not playing tonight.
You know,
I'm going to sit back and fucking drink a beer,
you know,
but I want you to get,
five,
six days in ag,
a nice little run going here,
little cal Ripken junior,
junior,
junior going on here,
right?
I want to see how long I can go,
blah,
blah.
And um,
I went to the Er,
I went to the store and I got a bunch of those little fucking plastic tins of a
bunch of Veggie shit and I just shoved that down my pie hole.
And now I got my body crave and that again,
I swear to God,
man,
I swear to God.
Um,
the amount of people who are fucking addicted to sugar and salt,
um,
has to be off the charts,
but I might be doing that thing where,
um,
taking my life and it and superimposing it on everybody else's.
You know what I mean?
Like,
well,
if I suffer from this,
then you must suffer from it.
But I'm telling you,
all I have to do is wake up in the morning by Dubai dot boob and I just oatmeal
with a fucking banana in it.
That fills me up.
And then if I go and I get a salad,
okay,
well the fucking protein for lunch,
it's over.
Then that's all it takes to kind of break that sugar,
salt,
sugar,
fucking horseshit going back and forth.
Pizza,
cookies,
ice cream,
fucking burger fries,
and you feel it.
You feel yourself going off the rails.
I'll fucking hyped up on the salt.
I got to get some sugar.
I got,
I got fucking level.
Yeah,
you'd do a line of fucking sugar that levels you out.
Then you wake up the next day and both of them is still fighting inside your
body and you wake up.
What do you get now?
Do you get oatmeal?
No.
You grabbed the fruit loops,
you grabbed the fruit loops.
Then you walk out the door,
all hopped up on sugar.
You take a handful of,
you fucking literally empty out all the pretzels and just drink the salt at the
bottom of the bag just so you can get the fucking work,
you know?
When did you just keep chasing it?
So,
um,
I actually talked to somebody on Twitter,
actually sent me a little tweets saying that they started a eating,
like the sounds and everything and,
and they started craving that stuff when they dropped like 20 pounds.
You know,
obviously I'm known nutritional or fitness fucking Guru,
but I can't tell you if you just start eating that way.
It's impossible.
Who likes going to the fucking gym?
Nobody.
What would you rather do?
Would you rather spend 45 fucking minutes on a treadmill?
Oh,
just sit down and over the course of five minutes,
just eat a salad.
Yeah.
With some funny now you know chicken breast on there are some salmon.
Well maybe you just go like a total veggie one was some beans in there.
It's fucking over.
Once you rather do that,
then eating the shit you want to eat and then jumping on a treadmill,
wearing out your hips,
your knees and your feet.
Fucking trying to wrong to run one.
Oh,
let me walk the next mile.
Just eat a fucking salad.
Puts your feet up.
He just set,
last night when I watched the game,
I actually owe sitting at a cigar bar,
so I'm killing myself that way.
But as far as food goes,
I actually,
um,
what did I get?
I ordered this beats and goat cheese salad,
which back in the day I would be like,
you fucking pussy.
Right.
I threw that thing down.
My throat filled me up.
I wasn't hungry and I woke up today and uh,
you know,
my alabaster stomach wasn't sticking out as far as I thought it was going to
beat.
And we have made me happy and woke up this morning.
Happy seeing that and what did I do?
Did I have to lift a bunch of weights?
They have to run up and down the fucking street.
They have to do a bunch of burpees standing in the sand next to some fucking
tanned up check.
Who's never going to fuck me?
No,
I didn't.
I just sat in a fucking lazy boy and fueled my body with the Goddamn Salad.
Can't recommend it enough.
Having said all that,
I don't know shit about nutrition.
Oh No.
If you get a fucking beat and goat cheese salad with a little cabin,
eyes fucking pecans in,
that's absolutely delicious.
I highly recommend it.
I want you guys walking around fucking being fat.
Fuck.
She wants to be a fat.
Fuck you there in the back.
You want to be a fat fuck.
Well good for you.
All right,
let's get a,
let's get to the other advertisement then.
I'm going to read some of these letters for the week.
All right.
stamps.com everybody,
you know that feeling you get when you can't get things done with just the click
of your mouse.
Uh Oh no,
I just read the turnaround.
You know that feeling you get when you can get things done with just the click
of your mouse.
It can't get more convenient than that.
See that?
I swear to God I had,
my eyes are like 20 feet ahead of my mouth,
so I went by the first can and then I read the can't.
All right,
let me just put it in my own words.
You know that feeling you get when you got your feet up and you want,
you've got a bunch of stuff to do but you don't even have to get off your ass.
You just click a mouse.
Wouldn't that be great?
Well it was stamps.com that can be yours and now you can even get your mailing
and shipping done without ever leaving your desk.
Thanks to stamps.com yet another reason to eat a salad,
you don't.
You have to get up to go to the post office anymore.
stamps.com turns your PC or Mac and your own personal post office that never
closes.
That never has an attitude that's never out of stamps.
Talk about convenient by in this is this,
this is my fucking contractor.
I swear to God.
This mother fucker.
Hang on a second.
All right.
False alarm wasn't a contract and he's not a fucking contract.
He's just a guy who comes up to me and I owe a bunch more money.
Hey,
did you notice that the roof isn't attached to the top of the house?
All right,
let's get back to the here.
Uh,
then,
okay,
you buy,
you can buy and buy and print official US postage for any letter or package
using your computer and printer.
Then just hand your mail to the mailman or drop it in the mailbox and you'll
never have to go to the post office again.
I use stamps.com to send out all of my posters,
tee shirts,
whatever crap I'm selling at the end of the,
uh,
the end of my stupid show right now.
Use My last name,
burp bur for this special offer.
No risk trial.
Plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale,
calculates exact postage for letters and packages and up to $55 free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarbecuerrthatstamps.com
enter burr.
All right,
let's get to the questions for this week.
Japan.
Uh,
dear Billy,
I w I'm wondering when you're going to come to Japan and if there's a reason you
have not.
You have spoken about the food many times as being your favorite along with the
Italian.
The countryside is beautiful,
so you could,
you could get an a good hike,
uh,
love you and love Nia.
Well,
you know what,
Surf,
you tell me where I can go perform over there.
Are there enough English speaking Japanese that are going to understand my
humor?
Because I would love to go to Tokyo.
I would.
I would love to go to Japan.
You know what?
I'm going to fucking make this happen.
That's it.
I'm going.
You tell me where to go.
You write me back?
I know that there's obviously,
we still have bases over there from that whole world war.
Two things.
Sorry about that,
by the way.
You know,
I know we went a little hardcore with the second one.
Um,
so it's about time I come over there with little fucking olive branch and do my
stupid,
uh,
you know,
he's stupid little fucking,
uh,
tricks there.
Little somersault here,
little punchline there,
do it.
I would absolutely love to go over there.
Um,
I,
uh,
you know,
obviously huge fan of the food,
huge fan of the fucking architecture and everything that I've seen over there,
both the old and the new,
that whole thing where you fucking beat all those dolphins to death.
I don't know about that shit,
but I'm sure you're not doing it.
Whatever.
Look at that already.
We've got some comedy there.
I don't know shit about your country there.
I said it,
but I want to go.
I've never been to Asia.
I'd love to go over there.
I'd love to go to Japan,
see the Great Wall and all of that shit.
I'm kidding.
I know that that's in China.
All right,
let's not get crazy.
I do.
This is what I know about Asia.
Okay.
As far as I know,
the Japanese are basically the white people of Asia in that they feel that they
are the most superior and over the course of the centuries,
they have tried to
impose their will on the other people around them.
Is that true?
Why would you,
why would I say this about the country that wants me to go there because I'm a
fucking moron.
Then you've got Korea,
you've got North Korea,
you got South Korea,
North Korea has that.
Uh,
one of the rarest things you'll ever see in the world,
which is an odd shape.
Asian guy running their country.
Okay.
The North Koreans,
so all the North Korean people are starving in.
This guy's walking around as basically a fat face.
Top of Shit is what kills me about this guy.
Okay.
If you can,
to be a dictator,
you know,
you got to feed you if you want it to last.
I guess his dad was able to starve everybody.
Dude,
if I was a dictator I would be such a good shit.
No one would try and take me over.
You know,
I wouldn't be out there raping and pillaging.
I would run it nice.
It will be all my fucking rules.
But I would be a nice guy about when people go,
you know what kind of getting sick of that.
I'd be like,
you know,
I can see that.
I can see that now because I really see it just because I don't want you guys to
eventually come and make an attempt on my life.
So you know what?
What would you like?
See I don't have the backbone to be a,
and then he got China,
you got a Zillion fucking people,
which isn't that kind of Japan's fault cause we,
they kept invading them.
So then they were like,
we're going to have so many fucking people that no matter,
no matter how many of us you killed is going to be another wave coming over and
now look at them.
God Damn air over there was like Brown.
What else do I know?
Do I know anything positive?
Do I know anything positive.
Yeah.
I know something positive.
All the martial arts come from there.
You've got yoga came up from fucking India.
Yeah.
Uh,
but I know you guys had a wonderful life until the English got there and fucked
everything up,
which is pretty much,
you know what,
that's the default answer around the world.
Yeah.
Everything was going great and then the English people came there and said,
all right,
these people here a little bit better than those people.
They're a little bit better than those people there and we're running shit and
go fuck yourself.
Settle in for the next hundred years.
And uh,
then you'll force this out.
Then we're going to leave and you guys can continue fighting this fight that we
created that never really existed cause you really all the same people who
should love one another and get along.
Right.
Anyways,
Beatles album bill,
dear Billy,
100.7 FM,
a buddy of mine recently got in an argument over which has,
which has Beatles album.
Do you guys even reread?
What the fuck he wrote?
A buddy of mine recently got in an argument over which Beatles album is probably
your favorite real intellectual stuff going on over here.
Just making fun of himself.
Ah,
I'm saying,
I'm saying it's let it be or the white album.
He's,
he says it's a rubber sole.
Um,
oh,
come on man.
How do you pick a favorite Beatles album?
I mean,
I definitely like their shit after,
uh,
you know,
they did,
they weren't clean cut.
Just singing like,
okay,
you know,
where's [inaudible] name is now?
I hate that shit.
She loves you.
Yeah.
Hate that shit.
But when they grow out the hair and started doing drugs,
I love all of that shit.
Um,
but it's been so long since I've listened to them.
I,
I'll have to get back to you on that one.
What's amazing about beetles music is the,
uh,
is the shit that they talk about.
It's still fucking timeless.
What's that wants to harm?
Looking through you?
Where did you go?
I thought I knew you.
What did I know?
You don't look dear Fred,
but things have changed.
I'm looking through you.
You're not the same,
right.
That's just classic.
When you're in a fucking relationship,
when you're young and you think you're really into this person and just one day,
the way they answer the phone,
hi,
they just do something.
He just like,
ugh.
Just like this isn't,
you think they changed?
It's just you're just learning more about the person and you're realizing like,
guys,
this isn't,
this isn't what I thought it was going to be.
Kind of like my house.
So I liked that one.
I also like,
obviously like the white album
I like,
I love let it be,
I mean sergeant pepper may come on and then he got real Volvo.
I like all of those.
You know?
You know what's funny is it's been so long since those albums come out that
there's a lot of young people that think the Beatles actually aren't,
is there are or they stink.
And um,
that,
that's just because all that fucking music has come out since then.
It's completely ripped them off.
It's kind of like the Richard Pryor thing where how fucking brilliant he was.
And then after like the fifth or sixth season of def jam comedy,
well everybody was doing those white people do this.
Black people do that shit.
And it was just,
it turned in from Richard Pryor's specific white guy that he was doing to just
that generic,
ah,
I've got to go do my taxes.
It,
it just kind of took away some of the shit that he was doing.
The only way to try it because there's no way to go back in time.
The only way to try to like
get yourself in that head space,
look at like a top 20 out top 100 and see what else was in the top 10 and listen
to that shit versus the Beatles album.
Um,
I guess that's the closest thing I would say.
I dunno,
who knows.
Anyways.
All Right,
Bill,
I'm a female and I love your comedy.
Oh my God.
Ding,
Ding.
We have a winner.
Well,
I'm going to be cliche and start by telling you what a huge fan of [inaudible]
yet,
but thank you.
Thank you so much.
Uh,
I have so many female friends that the are the,
are the epitome of what you say about them.
No Day off for their man are constantly wanting to fix or change them.
I've always been pretty mellow and from what my husband says,
I am a dude trapped in a girl's body.
I'm sure he might be exaggerating a bit,
but it makes me smile to know he thinks that I'm cool.
Oh yeah.
That's one of the best compliments you can get if a guy,
if he your boyfriend or husband or whatever thinks you're cool.
Um,
and I know I'm not trying to be a fucking sexist.
Can't hear like,
oh,
you should be.
Oh Wow.
I'm so flattered that you fucking gave me that compliment.
All right.
Don't get your tits in an uproar here.
I'm just saying if,
if,
if the guy in your life actually,
if you're fun to hang out with,
that's a very rare thing because usually we're trying to get away from you.
Um,
anyways,
she says,
I'm rambling now.
You know,
for now,
you know,
for sure I'm a woman.
Uh,
she goes,
I spoke,
I saw this quote from a movie and wanted to share it with you.
Uh,
do not try to change him.
That's why so many marriages fail before he removes the wedding veil.
The wife starts to change the husband's happiness,
his thoughts,
his friends.
And when she's brainwashed him and re mothered him completely,
she wonders what happened to the man that fascinated her.
The one she fell in love with.
Just a thought.
Just thought you would enjoy that.
And hopefully one of these days we'll be able to see you live.
You were on our bucket list.
Joking.
Uh,
thanks for your time.
Faithful Fan.
No.
These two emails deal with the same situation.
Might want to read both together and give one answer.
Oh,
that's from,
uh,
my guy here.
All right,
well I'll read them both together then.
How to change gears with the lady.
Hey Bill,
I've been away from home for nine months and whenever I get a little blue
missing friends and family from back home,
I just tossed in your Po.
I've got enough.
The compliments,
no one won.
I appreciate him.
But,
uh,
people just want to hear the question here.
I was hoping you could give me some advice.
I'm living in a little house in Indonesia with a lady who had been best friends
with for six years.
We're staying here for the next month.
I hadn't seen this girl in over a year before we met up a few days ago.
Problem is in the last couple of days.
I've totally fallen for her.
Oh.
[inaudible] I'm not sure why I never felt this way about her until now.
Probably because you're in fucking Indonesia.
You know,
that's probably,
we'd probably in the middle of fucking nowhere.
And you just see your only option.
You have the most beautiful girl.
I remember.
Uh,
we've always made each other laugh and always loved the same things,
but we never
gotcha.
What am I going to do here?
I'm just going to let it ring.
Who answers their home phone anymore?
Hi,
my name is Bert Lundquist and I'm running for fucking state cutlet.
Whatever the fuck it is.
We've always made each other laugh and always loved the same things,
but we never,
we just never went the boy,
uh,
beyond a friendship.
Now I'm really jealous when I see her around other guys.
So here's my big idea.
I was thinking about asking her out on a date.
Okay.
Why don't I have the default ringer at like two rinks.
Because I never do anything to make my life easy.
One more
and that should be it.
Dude.
I fucked by.
You can't.
All right.
Anyways,
he goes,
I know.
It's weird because we're sharing a house
and we know each other so well,
but I thought it would be better to just say,
do you want to go on a date with me?
And then offered to take her out for dinner?
Are you fucking serious?
And to see a band?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Who is on the other end that isn't hanging up yet?
I'm going to pick that up and it's going to go seven days.
I'm not picking up
Chris.
All right.
We know each other so well,
but I thought it would be better to just say,
do you want to go on a date with me and then offer to take her out for dinner
and to see a band like a,
what if this was someone I just met?
Rather than make some heavy confession about my feelings that way it's more of a
fun thing.
We could try rent,
we could try rather as more of a funding we could try rather than some big
series decision she has to make.
I thought if she was a bit reluctant,
I might try saying that a friendship is strong enough to survive one bad date.
Dude,
I think you're killing it right now.
I would have never thought to do that.
I would have been like good too low.
You feel though.
Fuck that.
I like what you're doing.
I like it way better.
So am I am more than for thinking this.
Absolutely not.
Is this just going to make our month together and uh,
in this place awkward and potentially ruin the trip?
Should I just keep my mouth shut and try to enjoy the fact that this amazing
woman is my friend.
Thanks in advance,
Bill.
You're one of a kind.
I know that I tried to ask the,
listen,
I think you should do exactly what you want to do.
Who knows?
Maybe these feelings are real.
Maybe they are not.
And you know,
you wouldn't be a man if you didn't ruin a friendship with your Dick.
You know,
everybody does it.
Everybody does it.
And I don't know how that tied into the one above here,
but uh,
I think you're killing it.
But as far as that quote that that woman said,
um,
okay.
Yeah,
I would agree.
I would agree with that.
But I also think guys do the same thing.
Guys do the same.
You don't want to,
you know what also happens,
I think in a relationship is you get so comfortable if you forget to keep
yourself looking good around each other,
you know what I mean?
Is there anything fucking worse than when you interrelationship and you,
you,
your girlfriend is just comfortable coming out.
Just dress like shit.
And I'm not saying that she always has to get fucking dolled up,
but you know,
it's the end of the night.
We're going to go watch a watch a fucking movie,
you know?
How long does it take to put on some fucking cute little Pajama fucking half
little horse halter top kind of thing?
You can't do that.
That takes two seconds.
Put your hair in a fucking pony tail bank,
bank,
boom.
You come out,
you make me feel like good.
Yeah.
All right.
I know I am.
I made a good choice here.
Yeah,
you come out,
you're fucking yes.
You know,
and that God damn fat suit,
whatever the funny and I'll it sweatpants and a hoodie.
Yeah.
Toes all fucked up.
I mean,
I,
and I just,
it's just,
you know,
it's,
it's off.
And then the same thing goes for the guys.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
All of a sudden you get a woman,
you started even fucking Mozzarella sticks and all that shit.
You coming out there with your wife beater and your man tits hanging out the
fucking side,
like John Bonham towards the end of his career,
that awful fucking picture when he's sitting down
this or this.
This is a critical thing when you're fat standing up too.
All right?
The last thing you need to do is fucking sit down with a wife Beater Ron.
Cause then it's just,
it's just the roles.
So they don't want to see that either.
Okay.
That's the thing is a guy,
man,
you got,
you know,
keep yourself in good shape,
shower and all that type of shit.
Just try to keep doing that throughout the fucking relationship.
Common out all fucking scruffy and bleary-eyed.
Okay.
You know,
working on a pair of man tits,
uh,
women don't want to look at that same way.
We don't want to look at them looking all fucked up.
So there you go.
Don't take the person you're with for granted.
All right,
look at me just telling everybody what the fuck did know.
last one I got to do and then I got it.
Gotta go to work.
Yep.
Bup,
bup,
Buh.
[inaudible].
All right.
Hey,
contraceptive pill bill.
I'm coming to the end of my high school life with just a few weeks ago and
there's one girl I've been waiting to ask out for awhile.
Well,
don't wait any longer.
Uh,
she's hot,
smart,
funny,
witty.
You fucking get it.
But she's in a different social group to me and I just know how I sh I just
don't know how I should go about asking route since we spent most of the past
two years taking the same classes yet I've barely talked to her.
How would you go about talking to this girl that you have spent a lot of time
around,
uh,
around you?
Uh,
you both know each other,
but you kept clear of,
I feel like if I don't make a move,
I'll regret not doing it for the rest of my life since she seems like she would
be an ideal girlfriend or response would be great.
Love the podcast.
Go Fuck yourself and get your alabaster ass down to Australia soon,
please.
All right,
dude.
Uh,
what we should do.
You should just go fucking ask her out because here's the thing.
Nothing bad will come of that.
Okay?
You won't have regret.
You'll fucking get over a fear which will help you further down the line.
And even if this woman says no,
now who knows?
Four or five years later,
you run into her and she remembered that you liked her.
You already broke down that fucking door.
You might banger or go out with their and fall in love with her ft of 50th
fucking high school union.
So this is what you do for this is what I wish I did.
This is what you do right here.
Fucking ask her up.
She says no,
just ask a bunch of them out.
Get Gino fucking lay the groundwork.
You like a salesman.
You may can pussy cold calls here right now for the rest of your high school
career.
And then you hit every fucking reunion and you show up with a God damn fucking
if some sunglasses and his fucking white scarf wrapped around your fucking neck
like a hero.
And I'm telling you,
you'll be fucking pulling pussy out of there like,
uh,
like those fucking Japanese guys club and those fucking dolphins to death.
It's a bad reference,
but you know what I mean,
that that's what you should do.
Should absolutely 100% ask her out or whatever.
Just come walking up to a,
how you doing?
She knows you fucking name.
She'll say a low back
and just say,
listen,
you know,
I've kind of been staring at your tits last couple of,
I don't say that.
Whatever.
It just fucking,
just ask around,
just fucking ascar out.
Nothing bad will come.
She has even,
even if she says no,
she might say to her friends,
she had believe who asked me.
Oh,
so and so asked you.
and one of them's going to respect it and be like,
I didn't know he had that in him.
Maybe one of them gets a little insecure.
Why he doesn't like my rock and fucking hoo ha.
And next thing you know,
you've got that coming down the pike.
Okay,
you got to get on the phone.
You got to make your calls in the morning or you don't get any sales at night.
All right,
that's the fucking point.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody go fuck yourselves.
Uh,
my prediction for the Patriots,
jets,
uh,
if it's at the Patriots,
I say we win if it's at the jets.
Um,
I don't know,
but I think it's going to be a close game despite the fact that the jets
allegedly suck in all of this shit.
This is the classic game
where gamblers fall into just looking at the numbers and looking at the records
and all of that shit.
And what you have to understand is every week what blows up your parlay.
There's always that game with something happened.
It makes no fucking sense.
All right.
The old chaos theory,
like Jurassic fucking park there.
I,
the jets always play as tough.
If we go in there and we kicked the shit out of him,
then they truly are a tough fucking team.
Um,
I dunno,
I just,
I don't,
I don't have faith in the Patriots.
I just feel like Tom Brady has been on his back the whole,
even yesterday I was on his fucking back more than I've seen.
He's been on his back more this fucking season.
I've seen in this goddamned career.
I still think we're working that out.
And Ridley went down and Mayo went down and I don't think,
obviously they're going to be back for the Thursday game.
I haven't looked at the sports page yet to see how bad it is.
So,
uh,
that's a huge blow to our defense and our running game.
So,
uh,
we got a lot closer to the fucking jets.
All right.
Take that with a grain of salt because I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about.
That's the podcasts.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.